[Music]
the question i get so often and a lot of
you want to know
does it get lonely
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
it's been another month since my last
life update video
a lot has happened i really have to get
better at posting these more often so i
don't have to cover so much in every
video but anyway we left off in montana
after backpacking in glacier national
park i actually hadn't planned on
leaving montana so soon but a heatwave
moved in and after three days of 100
degree temps nathaniel and i decided to
head for the coast for the first time
since last september we were finally
back in washington the land of cool
weather foggy mornings alpine lakes and
mountain views
but something fell off
i have been going through some rough
patches lately
but i know that in the grand scheme of
things just life in general like my
struggles are small and my words are
super minimal and this really just
pertains to road life but i did want to
touch a little bit about or touch a
little on the loneliness and solitude
that can
exist out here on the road um i know a
lot of you might be interested in this
lifestyle and the last thing i want to
do is create this
illusion that everything is always
rainbows and butterflies
um
for one like community and stability can
be really hard to achieve on the road i
personally am someone that
truly thrives off of routine
and yeah finding a way to have that
balance when you're constantly moving
around and every day looks different
that can be hard to do after arriving in
washington nathaniel and i actually
booked a two-week house sit near the
north cascades um this beautiful house
and there are actually no pets we were
just looking after a garden so it seemed
like the perfect way to kind of get out
of my funk
creatively and reset re-establish some
routines
and yeah just kind of take it easy but
after those two weeks i still felt like
something was off
and
for me personally that usually just
means one thing
i desperately needed some solitude and
alone time i have always been like this
even as a kid i'm an extroverted
introvert which is to say i love being
around people and i love big parties and
concerts and events but i need alone
time to recharge without it i just
become this different version of myself
like i'm grumpy tired uninspired i'm
just i'm hard to be around being in a
relationship with someone who also lives
on the road has made alone time
difficult to carve out for ourselves
not for any reason other than we like
being around each other and we've gotten
used to the convenience of being
together especially on the road there's
safety in numbers if one person gets
stuck the other can help out and if one
runs out of propane the other one has a
backup if a place feels kind of sketchy
we have two opinions instead of one
we're comfortable basing in the same
place together but doing our own thing
we work well together and all of that
makes it hard to make time for solitude
which got me thinking about loneliness
it's a question i get so often and a lot
of you want to know
does it get lonely
yeah
but
also maybe not in the way you might
think for me personally the loneliest
moments of my adult life have all been
in situations where i was surrounded by
people like a large dinner party or a
big group event usually a situation
where i'm going into it already feeling
really
socially drained and like i haven't had
sufficient alone time and i just fail to
connect with anyone on a deeper level
and i really struggle with the surface
level conversation
um i wind up feeling like i'm on an
island of people who just won't stop
talking and i feel lonely as hell i
thought about this for a few days while
recording and i truly cannot think of a
time in my adult life when i was
physically alone and lonely because of
it it's actually something i want to
explore further by maybe planning like
um a long through hike a solo through
hike or something at some point just so
that i can better understand where those
boundaries exist for me
but who knows i mean maybe i'm meant to
be one of those park rangers who live
off the grid in fire tower lookouts for
months on end i mean that does sound
kind of nice actually so i just finished
reading east of eden by john steinbeck
beautiful beautiful book by the way
there's this scene in the book where one
of the main characters goes to the bar
one evening he felt a crippling
loneliness for the close men in barracks
intent his impulse was to rush into a
crowd for warmth any crowd the first
crowded public place he could find was a
little bar thronged and smokey he sighed
with pleasure almost nestled in the
human clot the way a cat nestles into a
wood pile he ordered whiskey and drank
it and felt warm and good he did not see
or hear he simply absorbed the contact
i've never understood the craving to be
around large groups of people just for
the sake of physical presence because
i've spent most of my adult life doing
just that and it has always always
drained me you know like in in work
settings i used to be a manager
abercrombie fitch i was constantly
surrounded by people in college or when
i was a waitress or just people
everywhere all the time
and to me
that was an obstacle to be overcome to
think that those situations might fill a
person up that's such a foreign concept
to me um
and i feel like it's what we as a
society celebrate most you know we
assume that everyone wants to be the
life of the party everyone wants to be
the center of attention everyone wants
to be around
a whole lot of people like the more
people the better but that's not always
the case for some people it is um but
not for all of us just because you're in
a house with your friends and with your
family and with your community
you can still be lonely and just because
you're in a van all alone in the middle
of nowhere you can still feel full and
happy loneliness can look and feel
different for each of us and
i just think it's important that you
take time to look inside and understand
what you need in order to feel whole and
happy so that you can be the best
version of yourself and just show up for
others
and yourself in the best way so all of
that to say nathaniel and i did what we
have to do every few months we carved
out some alone time for ourselves and
said goodbye for about a week
i stayed in the mountains and then i
moved to the sea
and through it all i was just
alone
and it was beautiful
simple and exactly what i needed
[Music]
this is one of my favorite campsites
i've been here for a couple nights and
now i'm gonna go catch the ferry and
head over to the olympic peninsula
and it's so foggy and beautiful out here
right now oh yeah i forgot i have blocks
gotta go get those
i'm trying to catch a ferry in the next
30 minutes so i just threw these up here
as you can see they're not holding up
too well
like
busting under the weight of van but
now my van is really a storage unit
so i just went through the booth and the
guy said they are booked solid
all day and tomorrow if i want to stick
around and try to get on standby in two
and a half hours i can so i'm just kind
of debating like should i hang around
here and keep looping around and trying
to get on or
drive but the drive is six and a half
hours and if i take the ferry it's only
three and a half hours so
not really sure what i'm gonna do yet
but for now maybe i'll just
hang out
[Music]
so i'm heading up this forest road to a
new spot that i've never been to before
i'm just like so burnt out on cities
and people
uh
i get really stressed out when i have to
be in a city for too long so
i'm excited to just
check out and be in the woods for a
while
[Music]
avocado
[Music]
basil sprouts
lemon
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
after about a week i met up with mariah
alice at the beach another female van
lifer whose channel i love because she's
just so raw and honest and also because
finn just might be the cutest dog ever
mariah is 22 and i'm 36 which is a
pretty big age gap i don't think either
of us really knew what to expect in
terms of conversation and whether or not
we'd actually have that much in common
but just four minutes after meeting we
were diving into deep questions no small
talk just straight to the real stuff
it's something that tends to happen
whenever i'm in the company of other
road lifers regardless of our age gaps
or life experiences it's as if we have
this mutual understanding that
everything is temporary and time is an
illusion
if you want to connect with someone on
the road you just go all in you skip the
small talk you make the most of the time
you have and share the stories that tie
you together because sooner or later
you'll continue down your own path and
drive away from one another it's kind of
sad but it's also really beautiful
goodbyes aren't really a thing on the
road it's always just the
see you later
after a week on the peninsula i drove up
to bellingham to reunite with nathaniel
mason and huxley were in the same area
so we based together for a few days near
the puget sound we spent our mornings
making coffee together at the park and
the afternoon's editing coffee shops
knights parked together in an overlook
by the sea it was nice almost like a
mini routine for a few days mariah
joined us a week later and we headed up
to mount baker for an overnight hike in
the mountains
ben
no no no
oh my god
he's so excited he loves it so pretty
much
[Music]
i'm filming
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
good
[Music]
morning have
we're almost there after our hike i hung
around baker for a little while longer
with my friend drew who happened to be
in the parking lot when mariah and i
hiked down some other friends rolled
through too which is one thing i love
about living on the road you never
really know who you'll run into or where
the day will take you
it's one of the main reasons i'm still
so committed to this lifestyle the
spontaneity and ever-present feeling of
adventure is just too good to pass up
a few days later my stepdad flew in from
kentucky and i spent some quality time
with him my little brother and my one
and a half-year-old nephew
it was so good to see them and reconnect
after so much time apart
looking back it's pretty eye-opening to
revisit all the ups and downs and
rollercoaster of emotions that i've
experienced just over the last few weeks
mostly i'm just grateful to be here you
know just like out here experiencing
these things and just living life out on
the road um
it's always an adventure never a dull
moment and yeah you just never know
where it will lead next so
um
thank you for being here and
thank you for a hundred thousand
subscribers
i
couldn't believe it i just hit it this
morning i'm really excited to keep
creating for you guys just like sharing
more about this lifestyle and your
support means so much so
i hope you guys are having a wonderful
day wherever you are and i will catch
you next time